le p créée 6 mai quelque chose un cas
d'école c'est à dire que personne
n'arrive à identifier exactement ce
qu'est le décret cisme donc valérie
pécresse par ce manque de notoriété ou
de colonne vertébrale qu'on lui prête
essaye de se mettre dans les pas un jour
de jacques chirac qui sont dix ans je
suis chiraquienne et se fait cogner
immédiatement par un nicolas sarkozy qui
selon des propos rapportés du figaro lui
reprochent de se dire chiraquienne alors
que c'est lui qui l'a fait ministre lui
dit qu'il apportera pas son soutien si
elle ne le cite pas plus lui le grand
nicolas sarkozy elle a un directeur de
campagne patrick stefanini qui était
celui de françois fillon est elle au
fond est plutôt du pays c'est à dire
qu'elle est prise en fait entre 4 quels
grands moments de la droite si on veut
dire n arrive pas à s'inscrire dedans et
il ya eric ciotti qui la tire plus vers
la droite dont le dit c'est mon passe
quoi pour essayer de faire croire
qu'elle serait le chirac de se passe
quoi la msa sans que ça marche et de
l'autre côté elle a des centristes comme
jean christophe lagarde avec qui elle
essaye de s'allier qu'il attire dans
l'autre sens oui et qui ne vont pas
faire bon ménage dans les criques ciotti
donc on voit bien que la synthèse ce
qu'est ce qu'elle est c'est fait au ps à
une époque avec françois hollande à
droite elle est très difficile parce que
c'est des camps qui ne peuvent pas
s'entendre et puis on voit aussi les
défections qui commence avec des calculs
comme eric woerth par exemple qui
choisit de soutenir emmanuel macron à
quelques jours de l'élection en misant
plutôt sur une victoire une réélection
dé me wade macron qu'une victoire de
valérie pécresse et combien vont faire
ce choix là avec la question des
investitures aussi c'est eric ciotti en
charge des investitures chez les
républicains donc ça ça doit fâcher
certains des cadors et des idées aux
cadres de ddd et républicains qui attend
des investitures qui se disent cette
fois ci je n'aurai pas ma chance avec
cette écurie là donc je vais aller voir
ailleurs c'est pas de la politique qui
plaît aux français de ce qu'on appelle
la politique politicienne c'est ce qui
fait je pense aussi l'adhésion à eric
zemmour parce qu'il ya pas encore ce
type de jeux d'appareil et c'est ce qui
fait que risque de voir encore beaucoup
d'abstention
pour ce premier tour de la
présidentielle